[Music]
we have different views sometimes they
actually stripped me of my humanity i'm
accused of stealing i'm accused of being
on drugs i'm being accused of putting a
hit on her kanye who was spotted out
yesterday having a blow up on his phone
posted then deleted some wild claims
about his ex kim a source tells e.t
kanye has been lashing out on social
media because he is really hurt and he
misses his kids but yesterday yay and
all black was joined by saint chicago
and psalm and hollywood unlocks jason
lee in downtown l.a for an event to
discuss disparities in black media
called the future brunch
kim's man pete davidson meanwhile was
booed by basketball fans in syracuse
pete who previously called syracuse
trash laughed it off and called for a
truce hello syracuse orangeman thank you
so much for having me we had a really
great time so
peace a source tells e.t kanye thinks
pete is a completely random choice and
that kim is making pete cooler as for
kanye's girlfriend well she thanked him
for all the birthday love as she turned
32 and shut down breakup rumors guys
relax i unfollowed the fan accounts
because i was tired of seeing myself
suddenly instagram was not a fun place
anymore
and get this julia shares a birthday
with wait for it kylie jenner's brand
new baby boy with travis scott the
couple announced the news with this
black and white photo of their
four-year-old daughter stormy holding
their son's tiny hand our source says
stormy is so thrilled that she gets to
be a big sister
the happy news reminded us of this kylie
throwback you want to be a mom someday
yes
i can't wait to be a mom even though i'm
15.
i would love to be alone
[Music]
you